he estado mirando a través del tiempo,
y he intentado encontrar otras sociedades
para ver si podrían tener ideas mejores y más lúcidas que las que tenemos
acerca de cómo ayudar a la gente creativa, a administrar
los inherentes riesgos emocionales de la creatividad.
Y esa búsqueda me ha llevado a la antigua Grecia y a la antigua Roma.
Así que manténganse conmigo, porque esto da la vuelta completa.
Pero, en la Grecia y Roma antiguas --
la gente no creía que la creatividad
venía de los seres humanos, ¿OK?
La gente creía que la creatividad era este espíritu asistente divino
que venía a los humanos de una fuente distante y desconocida,
por razones distantes y desconocidas.
Los griegos llamaron a estos espíritus divinos asistentes de la creatividad, "daimones."
Sócrates, popularmente se creía que tenía un daimon
que le hablaba con sabiduría desde lejos.
Los Romanos tenían la misma idea,
pero llamaban a este espíritu creativo incorpóreo un genio.
Lo que es genial, porque los Romanos no creían
que un genio era un individuo particularmente inteligente.
Ellos creían que un genio era este tipo de entidad mágica y divina,
que se creía, vivía, literalmente, en las paredes
del estudio de un artista, algo así como Dobby el elfo domestico,
y que salía y asistía invisiblemente al artista con su trabajo
y daba forma al resultado de ese trabajo.
Tan brillante -- ahí está, justo ahí esa distancia de la que estoy hablando --
ese constructo psicológico para protegerse de los resultados de tu trabajo.
Y todos sabían que así es como funcionaba, ¿verdad?
Así el artista antiguo estaba protegido de ciertas cosas,
como, por ejemplo, demasiado narcisismo, ¿verdad?
Si tu trabajo era brillante no te podías atribuir todo el mérito por él,
todos sabían que tuviste este genio incorpóreo que te había ayudado.
Si tu trabajo fracasaba, no era totalmente tu culpa, ¿saben?
Todos sabían que tu genio era algo débil.
Y eso es lo que la gente pensaba sobre la creatividad en Occidente por mucho tiempo.
Y entonces llegó el Renacimiento y todo cambió,
y tuvimos esta gran idea, y la gran idea fue
vamos a poner al ser humano individual en el centro del universo
sobre todos los dioses y misterios, y no hay más espacio
para criaturas místicas que toman dictado de lo divino.
Y es el principio del humanismo racional,
y la gente empezó a creer que la creatividad
venía completamente del individuo mismo.
Y por primera vez en la historia,
empiezas a escuchar a gente referirse a este o aquel artista como si fuera un genio
en vez de tener un genio.
Y debo decirles, creo que eso fue un gran error.
Saben, creo que permitir a alguien, una simple persona
creer que él o ella es como, el contenedor,
como la fuente, la esencia y el origen
de todo misterio divino, creativo, desconocido
es quizá demasiada responsabilidad para una frágil psique humana.
Es como pedirle a alguien que se trague el sol.
Deforma y distorsiona egos,
y crea todas estas expectativas inmanejables sobre el rendimiento.
Y creo que la presión de eso
ha estado matando a nuestros artistas los últimos 500 años.
Y, si esto es verdad,
y yo creo que es verdad,
la pregunta se vuelve, ¿ahora qué?
¿Podemos hacer esto de una manera diferente?
Tal vez regresar a una comprensión más antigua
sobre la relación entre humanos y el misterio creativo.
Tal vez no.
Tal vez no podemos simplemente borrar 500 años de pensamiento humanístico racional
en un discurso de 18 minutos.
Y probablemente hay gente en esta audiencia
que puede tener legítimas sospechas científicas
sobre la noción de hadas, básicamente,
que siguen a la gente frotando zumo de hada en sus proyectos y cosas así.
No voy a conseguir que todos estén de acuerdo conmigo.
Pero la pregunta que quiero presentar es --
¿Por qué no?
¿Por qué no pensar de esta manera?
Porque tiene tanto sentido como cualquier otra cosa que yo haya escuchado
en términos de explicar la enloquecedora arbitrariedad absoluta
del proceso creativo.
Un proceso que, como cualquiera que alguna vez haya intentado hacer algo conoce --
lo que es decir, básicamente todos los presentes --
no siempre se comporta racionalmente.
Y, de hecho, a veces puede sentirse definitivamente paranormal.
Hace poco me encontré con la extraordinaria poetisa norteamericana Ruth Stone,
que está ya en sus 90 años, pero ha sido una poetisa toda su vida
y me dijo que cuando crecía en su Virginia rural,
ella estaría trabajando en el campo,
y dijo que iba a sentir y oír un poema
que venia hacia ella desde el paisaje.
Y dijo que era como un atronador tren de aire.
Y vendría hacia ella descontroladamente sobre el paisaje.
Y lo sentía venir, porque hacía que la tierra temblara bajo sus pies.
Ella sabía que solo tenía una cosa que hacer en ese momento,
y era, en sus palabras, "correr como una endemoniada."
Y corría como una endemoniada a la casa
y era perseguida por este poema,
y lo que debía hacer era que tenía que conseguir un pedazo de papel y un lápiz
lo suficientemente rápido para que cuando tronara a través de ella, lo pudiera recoger
y atraparlo en la página.
Y a veces no era lo suficientemente rápida,
así que ella estaría corriendo y corriendo, y no llegaría a la casa
y el poema la atropellaría y ella lo perdía
y ella dijo que seguiría avanzando sobre el paisaje,
buscando, como ella dijo, "a otro poeta."
Y a veces existían estas ocasiones --
esta es la parte que nunca olvidé --
dijo que existían momentos en los que ella casi lo perdía, ¿verdad?
Así que, está corriendo a la casa y buscando el papel
y el poema la pasaba de largo,
y ella agarraba el lápiz justo mientras pasaba por ella,
y entonces ella dijo, era como si lo hubiera alcanzado con su otra mano
y lo hubiera atrapado.
Atrapaba el poema por la cola,
y lo tiraba hacia atrás dentro de su cuerpo
mientras lo transcribía en la página.
Y en estas ocasiones, el poema aparecía en la página perfecto e intacto
pero al revés, de la última palabra a la primera.
(Risas)
Así que cuando lo escuché pensé -- que extraño,
así es exactamente mi proceso creativo.
(Risas)
Eso no es todo mi proceso creativo -- ¡No soy la tubería!
Soy una mula, y la manera que tengo de trabajar
es que me tengo que levantar a la misma hora todos los días,
y sudar y trabajar y pasar por todo eso torpemente.
Pero aún yo, en mi mulismo,
aún yo me he rozado contra esa cosa, a veces.
Y me imagino que muchos de ustedes también.
Saben, incluso he tenido trabajo o ideas que vienen a mí desde una fuente
que honestamente no puedo identificar .
¿Y qué es esa cosa?
¿Y cómo podemos relacionarnos con ella sin que nos haga perder el juicio,
pero, de hecho, nos mantenga cuerdos?
Y para mí, el mejor ejemplo contemporáneo que tengo de cómo hacerlo
es el músico Tom Waits,
a quien entrevisté hace algunos años para una revista.
Y estábamos hablando acerca de esto,
y ya saben, Tom, por la mayor parte de su vida ha sido el ejemplo
del atormentado artista moderno contemporáneo,
intentando controlar y manejar y dominar
estos impulsos creativos incontrolables
que están totalmente interiorizados.
Pero entonces se volvió más viejo, más tranquilo,
y un día estaba conduciendo en la autopista en Los Ángeles me dijo,
y fue entonces cuando todo cambió para él.
Está conduciendo, y de repente
escucha este pequeño fragmento de melodía,
que viene a su cabeza como llega la inspiración a menudo, evasiva y sugerente,
y la quiere, ustedes saben, es hermosa,
y la añora, pero no tiene manera de conseguirla.
No tiene un pedazo de papel, no tiene un lápiz,
no tiene una grabadora.
Así que empieza a sentir esa vieja ansiedad crecer en él
así como, "Voy a perder esta cosa,
y entonces esta canción me va a atormentar para siempre.
No soy lo suficientemente bueno, no puedo hacerlo."
Y en vez de caer en el pánico, se detuvo.
Detuvo el proceso mental completo
e hizo algo completamente novedoso.
Simplemente miró al cielo, y dijo,
"Disculpa, ¿no ves que estoy conduciendo?"
(Risas)
"¿Te parece que puedo escribir una canción ahora?
Si realmente quieres existir, regresa en un momento más oportuno
cuando me pueda encargar de ti.
Sino, ve a molestar a alguien más.
Ve a molestar a Leonard Cohen."
Y su proceso de trabajo cambió por completo después de eso.
No el trabajo, el trabajo aún era a menudo tan oscuro como siempre.
Sino el proceso, y la pesada ansiedad a su alrededor
fue liberada cuando tomo al genio, y lo saco de su interior
donde solo causaba problemas, y lo liberó de vuelta al lugar del que vino,
y se dio cuenta que no tenía que ser una cosa interiorizada, atormentadora.
Podía ser esta colaboración peculiar, magnífica, extraordinaria
tipo de conversación entre Tom y la extraña cosa externa
que no era precisamente Tom.
Así que cuando oí esa historia, empezó a cambiar un poco
la manera en que yo trabajaba, y ya me salvó una vez.
Esta idea me salvó cuando estaba escribiendo "Eat, Pray, Love,"
y caí en uno de esos pozos de desesperación
en el que todos caemos cuando trabajamos en algo y no está funcionando
y empiezas a pensar que va a ser un desastre,
que va a ser el peor libro jamás escrito.
No solo malo, sino el peor libro jamás escrito.
Y empecé a pensar que debería de dejar el proyecto.
Pero me acordé de Tom hablandole al aire
y lo intenté.
Así que levante mi cara del manuscrito
y dirigí mis comentarios a una esquina vacía del cuarto.
Y dije en voz alta: "Escucha tú, cosa,
ambos sabemos que si este libro no es brillante
no es enteramente mi culpa, ¿verdad?
Porque puedes ver que estoy poniendo todo lo que tengo en esto,
no tengo nada más.
Así que si quieres que sea mejor, tienes que aparecer y cumplir con tu parte del trato.
OK. Pero si no lo haces, sabes, al diablo con esto.
Voy a seguir escribiendo porque es mi trabajo.
Y quisiera que quede reflejado hoy
que yo estuve aquí para hacer mi parte del trabajo."
(Risas)
Porque --
(Aplausos)
al final es algo así, OK --
hace siglos en los desiertos de África del Norte,
la gente se juntaba en bailes sagrados con música a la luz de la luna
que continuaban durante horas y horas hasta el amanecer.
Y siempre eran magníficos, porque los bailarines eran profesionales
y eran geniales, ¿verdad?
Pero de vez en cuando, muy raramente, algo pasaba,
y uno de estos interpretes se volvería trascendente.
Y yo sé que ustedes saben de lo que estoy hablando,
porque sé que todos han visto, en algún momento, una ejecución así.
Era como si el tiempo se detuviera,
y el bailarín pasaba por un tipo de portal
y no estaba haciendo nada diferente de lo que había hecho las mil noches anteriores,
pero todo se alineaba.
Y de repente, no parecía ser un simple humano.
Estaba iluminado internamente y desde abajo
y todo iluminado con divinidad.
Y cuando esto pasaba, en esos tiempos,
la gente sabía lo que era, saben, y lo llamaban por su nombre.
Juntaban sus manos y empezaban a cantar,
"Allah, Allah, Allah, Dios, Dios, Dios."
Eso es Dios, ¿saben?
Una curiosa nota histórica --
Cuando los moros invadieron el sur de España, llevaron esta costumbre con ellos
y la pronunciación cambió con los siglos
de "Allah, Allah, Allah" a "Olé, olé, olé,"
Que aún se escucha en plazas de toros y bailes flamencos.
En España, cuando alguien ha hecho algo imposible y mágico,
"Allah, olé, olé, Allah, magnífico, bravo,"
incomprensible, ahí está -- una visión de Dios.
Lo que es grandioso, porque lo necesitamos.
Pero, la parte difícil viene a la mañana siguiente,
para el mismo bailarín, cuando se despierta
y descubre que es martes a las 11 a.m., y él ya no es una visión de Dios.
Es solamente un mortal con malas rodillas,
y tal vez jamás logrará ascender a esas alturas de nuevo.
Y tal vez nadie más cantará el nombre de Dios mientras da vueltas,
¿Y qué va a hacer con el resto de su vida entonces?
Esto es difícil.
Es una de las reconciliaciones más dolorosas
en la vida creativa.
Pero tal vez no debe estar lleno de angustia
si ustedes no creyeran, en primer lugar,
que los aspectos más extraordinarios de su ser vinieron de ustedes.
Pero tal vez si simplemente se creyeran que era un préstamo
de alguna fuente inimaginable por una exquisita porción de su vida
para entregar a alguien más cuando hubieran terminado.
Y saben, si pensamos de esta manera, empieza a cambiar todo.
Así es como he empezado a pensar,
y es definitivamente como he pensado en los últimos meses
mientras he trabajado en el libro que pronto será publicado,
como la peligrosa, atemorizante sobreanticipada secuela
de mi extraño éxito.
Y lo que tengo que seguir diciéndome
cuando realmente me pongo nerviosa
es, no tengas miedo.
No te abrumes.
Solo haz tu trabajo.
Continúa presentándote para hacer tu parte, sea cual sea.
Si tu trabajo es bailar, haz tu baile.
Si el divino, absurdo genio asignado a tu caso
decide dejar que se vislumbre algún tipo de maravilla, aunque sea por un momento
a través de tus esfuerzos, entonces "¡Olé!"
Y si no, haz tu baile de todas formas.
Y "¡Olé!" para ti, de todas formas.
Creo en esto y siento que debemos enseñarlo.
"¡Olé!" a ti, de todas formas,
solamente por tener el amor y la tenacidad humana
de continuar intentándolo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
June Cohen: ¡Olé!